we have learned now about a seven year
old girl from Guatemala who died of
dehydration and septic shock while in
the custody of border patrol now I've
seen a range of reporting in terms of
how much guilt the Border Patrol has for
this death and I'm going to tell you the
story as accurately as I have been able
to research it and I know some people
aren't going to like this which is that
I don't know that we can really say this
death is the fault of Customs and Border
Patrol I think that the criticism that
we could make is that they were maybe
not fully equipped to identify what it
was that was going on with this girl
still horrible still a tragedy still a
criticism but let's go through the facts
first and see where we come out the
seven-year-old girl jacqueline am a
rosemary cal McKean was brought over the
us-mexico border illegally she was taken
into Border Patrol cus T she came over
with her father and was separated from
her father as is the policy a policy I'm
against and find absolutely disgusting
and despicable particularly when the
Border Patrol and ice are not equipped
to actually deal with the way they are
executing these separations eight hours
after being taken into Border Patrol
custody she started having seizures
according to their own records had a
fever of 105 point seven and ultimately
was brought to a hospital and died
within a day of being transported
officially due to dehydration and septic
shock and now an investigation of the
incident is underway a CBP spokesman
Customs and Border Patrol sent
condolences to the family and what we're
quickly learning here is that they are
just not equipped to manage these
situations so what I mean by that is as
follows you don't go into septic shock
and the type of dehydration that we're
talking about here from eight hours and
Border Patrol custody right that that's
schematically that's absolutely clear
this is a girl who in all likelihood had
a severe deficit of both food and water
for the entire time that she was coming
to the United States through no
of her own as a result of what her
father decided to do try to come to the
United States and seek asylum this is a
type of dehydration where Customs and
Border Patrol gave her water and food
but you need intravenous fluids you need
immediate medical attention so while the
criticisms and the debate has sort of
centered around well did
CBP give her food and water or didn't
they which did they dehydrate her the
evidence that I've seen is that Customs
and Border Patrol did provide food and
water very quickly to this girl but that
her condition from having spent time
exposed without food and water for so
long on the trek to the United States is
what created the sort of presenting
circumstances that led to death by
dehydration and septic shock now is this
a defense of Customs and Border Patrol
no it's not we've seen many deaths that
have taken place which we can directly
say are because of the actions of CBP
there's no question that there was some
negligence here and lack of preparation
by CBP but I think it's really important
Pat that we not parrot the incorrect
story that has been floating around
which is that she developed dehydration
and septic shock merely because of the
treatment by Customs and Border Patrol
that that's it's mathematically just not
the case it doesn't mean that this is a
good situation this is a tragedy CBP is
not equipped to handle these situations
they're one of the top Customs and
Border Patrol people recently said that
the the Border Patrol facilities were
built decades ago to handle single male
adults not families and not children so
the CBP bears responsibility they're a
huge part of this problem but in this
particular case to say that the actions
of CBP are what caused death by
dehydration and septic shock would
simply be incorrect and we hurt our
cause when we say things that aren't
true yeah I think the blame here has to
get shared partially by her father and
partially by Customs and Border Patrol
but the thing is it's not like this is
entirely a one-off circumstance like if
it was then you could probably get away
with giving them the benefit of the
doubt but given Trump's policy on
immigration the try
separation family separation stuff you
know this sort of thing can happen and
it just completely fits the narrative
and that's why I'm not willing to give
CBP a total pass here I completely agree
with you and what this is part of is the
big story which is that the system we
have in place is failing everyone it's
an immoral system it's a system no one
benefits from other than a for-profit
detention centers and the companies that
are taking advantage of cheap immigrant
labor American taxpayers don't benefit
other than the fact that of course the
entire system provides them with cheaper
products that they can buy but the
people coming to the u.s. to work or to
seek asylum the children that are being
brought along they don't benefit from
this system in fact they're hurt by it
and one of the things that's becoming
very transparent here is that the moral
imperatives that the right claims to
have around their activism are
completely bogus one sided political
props remember Pizza Gate that
conspiracy theory something like Hillary
Clinton is involved in child trafficking
through a pizza place in Washington DC
and the right said we care because we
care about children and Hillary doesn't
story was obviously bogus some pundits
ended up having to apologize for even
spreading it but here is a real story
about children who are actually
suffering and we hear stuff like hey man
just obey the law and it won't happen
right but it's the parents bringing
their kids how can a seven-year-old be
expected to know the law and to have
agency and to say you go ahead mom and
dad I'm gonna stay behind here in the
whatever country they're coming from
children are actually dying here pizza
gate was nothing where is every I would
love to see every single pizza gate
conspiracy theorists on this if they
care about children above politics but
sadly they don't seem to follow me on
Instagram at David Pakman follow the
show on Instagram at David Pakman show I
am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinka is a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning
but are busy blinka stakes the best and
most popular non-fiction books and
condenses them into 15-minute audiobooks
I'm sure that if you're like me you have
a very long list of books that you've
been meaning to read you only have so
many hours in the day and that's why
blink astiz so amazing they take the
most important information the themes
the insights from each book and they
distill it into a 15 minute audio book
that you can listen to in one sitting
I've listened to a ton of books on
blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink accom slash Pakman that's bli
nki st.com
/p a que ma n